ed a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono felice io ci siamo
tornati su minecraft marcoule
volevo spinge altri affoghi arti no
vabbè parte gli scherzi sento anche sul
minecraft sada di somain crafar cool
perché posso finire per cortesia la
frase poi fai quello di te lo giuro fai
quello che vuoi già dati su mac parkour
perché ho visto che vi piace un sacco e
non avrei mai detto niente quindi
continuiamo come battuta dell'unica cosa
di minecraft dove non faccio schifo
perché bisogna saltare è vero perché
tutti vi dico se le fai schifo a giocare
manca però in questo non possono dirlo
perché basta saltare levate
ecco come non è se non avessi pietro
farei anche più bravi spieghi con quale
fisica stai pretendendo di fare questa
cosa posso fare io posso
grazie allora come si fa
hai visto bravi come portarli al primo
colpo tra l'altro no che ha capito il
tasso per usare quindi questo caso di
questa cosa è ben capito benissimo hai
capito già fatta nuovo porca eva morta
ce l'ho fatta non so come tu devi
crederci un pro players di gravi un pro
player ci riesce a voi picchiarmi mentre
sull sistema non funziona veramente
guarda guarda aspetta il di spinto
orgoglio che va avanti di buono 2 se la
picchiano i picchi sempre quando vidi
picchiare dai al mio 3 1 2 bassi da
morena una volta aiutato se in un
soggetto sito aperto pietro e pergine ha
inizio credo in te si
sono fatto ciò fatto incredibile devi
saltare devi guardare proprio il lago
vabbè io vado avanti
ciao amico ciao s'è fatta no no vabbè
contro il control bravissimo so provato
per un attimo sperando credo si faccia
così presumo ma dico sera c'erano già
stati sì c'è tutto questo bordello per
salire su non è vero tutto sto bordello
occhio che se carino se carico a pezzi
veramente dalla parte di satana è ok
occhio cioè tutto sto bordello per
salire una staccionata sei serio
no non è vero se non ci voglio credere
ma per una cagata arriva a dio mio
prego amico perché grazie a gesù è stato
difficile ma ce l'abbiamo fatto sono
orgoglioso di noi ragazzo mio nome
orgoglioso per questo è semplice dai fin
qua ci arrivi stavi fare qua oggi ho
ancora sull'islam schifosi che odio ti
fai anche un male boia
se infatti ecco perché non so non è
difficile perché non c'è saltare tu non
volevo capire se bisogna fare
qualcos'altro occhio occhio occhio ecco
cosa succederà guardali guardare
avevo sentito
quindi se io avessi il potere di dio
quando ha conficcato satana negli inferi
che lo giuro su quello te lo giuro che
ti avrebbe conficcato nel centro della
terra non ti saresti più mosse 0 wifi
guarda qua no dai
ma ma ma dici veramente il latte scena
da dove scrivere perché io ho fatto
splash ed ero già allibito poi ho
sentito un altro splash ho detto mi
chiami sembrava fossi caduto anche tu
pensa che sfiga se guarda guarda non ho
veramente parole non so neanche
descrivere questa cosa ti odio
se la persona che di più odiato in tutta
la mia vita amico so come fare una cosa
e come allora seconda questo la pedana a
quindi se uno muore riparte dalla pedana
allora avevano un senso avere un senso
ma non puoi farla st parte stavo
scherzando puoi fare mai fatto ok pietro
io ho dei problemi te lo giuro
cosa è successo come hai fatto a salire
sull'albero a cieli della sinistra ok
pensa se fosse come getting over it che
quando cadi non puoi tornare dove il
papa è va bene ne amori n ho capito come
fare comunque c'era arrivato al cav h
arrivato qua verrà qualcosa poi il giro
che di lei non posso di sì
ci ha provato pensa che volevo picchiati
per farti cadere ma non c'è bisogno
quanto pare la caduta da sola grande
guarda mia vita tu mi hai dato una mano
per un attimo
no no ma dai non ci voglio credere
no no no no no no no io no come come
fatto da novanta come lui stasera su
bravo pietro bravo becco dai maledizione
prendi c'è poi dai preso troppo dura
della mia uccido vaffan correva odio suo
livello è stato bruttissimo perfetto
questo è ancora più difficile
questo bisogna fare qua m'ammazza sedere
che poi non sono capace se ti fai tu non
ci credo no dai
e vabbè questa data ci ero riuscito poi
penso questo provoca come ci arrivo poi
si arriva da qua dove sanno dove andare
giù ma non ci arrivo lì c'è un muro
davanti a me alta a destra il muro a ok
ora slime giampà guardarono poi costa
volendo lancioni dell'acqua dell'acqua
premia che le mani grazie
ok hai fatta vieni vieni sto andando a
fuoco da nora aia
ok ce l'ho fatta io
io porto vado a fare la scelta più
facile morire ma quando non funziona è
una cagata basta saltare salta salta
anche se vai a fuoco salta che
bellissimo ed attendere a fuoco mentre
tanta non si ferma la salita e poi da
qui è su una scala o va bene non ho idea
di dove andare poi dopo però come hai
fatto a cadere capirla ah ok ok ok ce
l'ho fatta ho fatta fenomeno è mossa ma
giochiamo un'altra roba
non è vero sono morto come video mio zio
oddio ce l'hai fatta ci hai fatta
il pezzo finale è difficilissimo devi
fare zig zag chi non riesco neanche a
saltare da un pezzo all'altra ciao mamma
mia
number one mamma mia cos'è sta roba sul
letto certi slogan più che non li state
ne hai rotto
credo che bisogna andare col suo passo
pro capite non so come o che hai fatto
salta niente cena sulla sua torcia ce la
fa la giocata sono pieni vieni vieni qua
è un mezzo casinò però proviamoci
questo che qualche la testa
ok buono qua la testa cpa malissimo però
ce l'ho fatta occhio a parte è
abbastanza difficile ma fattibile
allora hai presente essere stupidi non
so se ci hai presente ecco quello da
mamma mia che palle non vale sempre più
avanti se episodio nell'altro da sempre
io a fargli fare control e corri avanti
con le 6 in volo premi shift la grappa
artista e lasci stare circa contro le tv
a guardare poi così avanti poi esatto
pare adesso sì che ho capito ok ce l'ho
fatto ho dovuto fare un change di tasti
incredibile come fatto a cadere qua
scusa è stato trovato lo salta ma porca
vacca morta impossibile grazie grazie
amico grazie cia viene viene
prego volevi guardarmi cadere per questo
pezzo bellissimo ragazzo è fatto è
risultato che prima non avevamo fatto
così prima stavamo scherzando è stagione
strano questo gioco è strano check point
be nice
sì sì no no ad ora pagherà infatti vi è
cioè quello no ma cosa bisogna fare con
questo ti incazzare cento oltre più a
farlo bisogna fare di volare
no basta ghiaccio no qua dei ragazzi
spero che video di noci vi sia piaciuto
per oggi concludiamo qua sta diventando
sempre più difficile però noi in teoria
non parlo perché in genere quando parlo
porto sempre sfiga quindi facciamo
schifo quello che vide sia piaciuto
ragazzi qualsiasi un certo punto mi
piace che la ricerca dato 10 a tutti i
[Musica]